welcome back to las vegas now this
weekend is not only valentine's day but
it's also presidents day weekend
and to celebrate john bar is offering
huge savings at finley toyota check this
out
a heart-shaped box filled with
chocolates makes a wonderful valentine's
day gift
but then again so does a brand new
toyota
hey john happy valentine's day wow jc
thank you i didn't know you felt that
way about
of course you're one of my favorites
here in las vegas now not only is it
valentine's day this weekend it's also
president's day weekend and you have
some huge specials going on
tell us what you have big specials
complimentary registration on all new
cars
and our blowouts as far as our 2020s
that still remain here
don't have many left want to get rid of
every one of them now the complementary
registration it's savings it's me on two
levels one you're saving a lot of money
and you're saving time because you have
to go to the dmv and deal with
everything
correct we have a service that helps
with that as well so
it can be like a one shop stop
correct yeah it works for me sounds good
did i say that right i think so
and then i've got the shop at the stop
the wrong way around one stop yeah you
get it all done here at finley toyota we
do
and you have every time i come down here
i feel very safe all kinds of covered
protocols in place
well thank you we do we have obviously
got our own equipment that we've
purchased
we have deep cleans every day and uh we
know the importance of keeping things
safe during these times really soon
you know john finley toyota is kind of
like it's like a box of chocolates you
never know what you're going to get when
you come down that's for sure j.c
in fact we have something for everyone
whoa oh god you like that i i do
i like that that's a beautiful
highlander well you deserve it we can
arrange that we can get you that new car
why not
oh cool sure did you have specials on
this this weekend we have specials
specials not only just the company
registration we're going to give you
but on top of that you've got rebates or
interest rates is your choice
all right do the snap again
[Music]
whoa this snapping thing is cool and so
is
this is a crawler this is a corolla yes
it is in fact
2021 corolla but of the vehicles we got
the special special special deal on
we have 20 20s in the crows so so this
weekend the 2020. this is the 21 the
2020 crawlers you got to move them out
of here right we do
we do can i can i try the snap thing try
it
try it
a slide jc leave the snap into me please
[Music]
yeah oh this is what i'm talking about
john
you like this one i i love this one when
did you guys bring back the supra i came
back last year
2020 and this is a 2021 model in canary
yellow
canary yellow is the color for jc now
this weekend with the complimentary
registration does that apply to this car
it does it does now janna i brought you
your valentine's day gift you got one
for me
i think you know what you want and i
think i know what you want
i will see you later my friend see you
later happy president's day happy
valentine's day
i'm out of here all right we need the
snap effect in all of your
all of your future packages finley
toyota is located in henderson call them
at 702-566-2573 or visit
findlaytoyota.com we'll be right back